[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando falamos racismo na maior parte
das vezes a primeira coisa que nos vem à
memória é a imagem de alguém que
discrimina direta e intencionalmente uma
pessoa se ana uma pessoa negra
este é com certeza um ato
discriminatório reprovava mas para
entender o racismo na educação é preciso
ir pra lá em do racismo interpessoal
racismo fosse uma questão de 1 para 1
uma questão pessoal
nós não teríamos um padrão tão
persistente daquelas que são
discriminados em qualquer parte do mundo
e em um longo período histórico os
grupos que são discriminados tendem a
ser os mesmos população negra a
população cigana e os grupos
étnico-raciais o racismo também não é
apenas uma questão intencional
é verdade que existem pessoas
manifestamente racistas
existem grupos de extrema direita e
assistimos agora ao recrutamento desses
grupos em toda a europa mas há uma
dimensão não intencional e não
consciente do racismo e fascismo também
não é propriamente uma questão das
festas e bispos que pensa em por
analogia com as questões de gênero
uma boa parte das desigualdades de
gênero mais fortes não se precisamente
em relações afetivas entre com os entre
um pai e uma filha entre o irmão e uma
irmã
tanta desigualdade em fetos muitas vezes
até andam de mãos dadas
o racismo também não é ignorância por
vezes dizemos anos esta especial da
temos medo daquilo que desconhecemos é
porque não conhecemos o outro
se assim fosse então os grupos que
seriam alvo de racismo mais marcado
seria um presentão islandeses
finlandeses e suecos
os quais não temos uma posição própria
mente histórica próxima
os grupos que sofrem mais racismo em
portugal são precisamente em que os com
os quais existe uma maior proximidade
com as comunidades ciganas estão em
portugal são portugueses
há pelo menos 500 anos a relação de
portugal com áfrica com os africanos e
que a população negra também tem outros
tanques séculos
se pensarmos que por exemplo lisboa
entre os séculos 16 e século 18
chegou a ter 10 por cento da sua posição
a composição negra em lácteos
os números eram precisos em évora em
alcácer do sal e muitos outros filhos
é preciso que o racismo é no fundo um
gato colonial tem que ver com a história
eu sei que neste momento quando começa a
falar sobre isso normalmente
muitos clubes estão a vir começam a
socorrer se de uma narrativa que permite
negar a existência do racismo que é
muito velha que se chama luz o
tropicalismo
é uma narrativa que foi usada na
propaganda do estado novo a partir da
década de 50 quando os impérios
coloniais em todo o mundo começava a
ruir e portugal para legitimar a sua
presença colonial em áfrica é preciso
criar um imaginário de uma nação
multirracial dor e continental e que os
portugueses teria uma capacidade quase
inata para uma colonização amigável e
pacífica esta ideia pareceu ainda há
pouco tempo escrita num livro de
história do 5º ano as condições dos
portugueses com os africanos e os
ameríndios no brasil tem sido uma
relação amigável e pacífica e por isso é
importante não perder o norte e
lembrarmos portugal esteve envolvido e
foi um dos principais responsáveis na
escravatura de milhões de africanos que
transportou esse milhões de africanos
nas costas africanas para para a américa
foi dos últimos impérios coloniais a
cair com uma guerra longa 3
anos das mais longas do conjunto dos
impérios coloniais
é preciso também lembrar que apesar de
não existir apartai para do período
colonial português
- uma coisa que chamava tudo indignado e
com o estatuto do indigenato legitimava
seu trabalho forçado e legitimava mas as
próprias são terras
a obrigação do cultivo determinado tipo
de culturas
invocava a idéia da inferioridade dos
africanos
a idéia é que o gilberto freyre passa um
livro se chamar casa grande senzala quer
miscigenação é uma marca do clube junto
deles como algo romântico na verdade foi
feito a partir da violência do corpo dos
corpos de mulheres negras mas o racismo
não é apenas uma repetição da história
né velhos hábitos que são repetentes já
sem sentido
o racismo só preciso porque ele é
demente relações de poder que exista uma
relação de poder há uma relação de poder
existe uma parte dessa relação que
retira privilégios e outra parte que
fica subalternizada é assim que por
exemplo uma entrevista de emprego e na
procura do empréstimo bancário numa
pressão policial
a população branca está sempre em
vantagem
tem ou não intenção cair ou não isso
aconteça mas se for a comunidade negra a
comunidade cigana provavelmente vão ter
piores resultados aí eu queria te dar um
exemplo que é um exemplo paradigmático
da questionamos branco e tudo
não sei se recordam de uma escola no
norte de portugal este carnaval mascarou
os seus alunos de africanos imediato
socorreu-se todo um imaginário dos
africanos como tribais como primitivos
canibais experimento em imaginar uma
turma mascarada de brancos não socorre
não funciona pois não é que não existe
um lugar da união não existe uma
história de suporte permita dar sentido
essa é exato do lar do racismo não é
ocultar outras formas de desigualdade de
gênero e de classe e outras estas
relações de poder é na realidade
articuladas
é o que se chama a intersexualidade por
outro lado se pensaram se tivermos em
conta que o racismo do corte total da
união e que korda uma relação de poder
a ideia de que existe racismo inverso
não faz sentido alguém que é negro ou
cigano ser preconceituoso com alguém que
é branco
ainda que seja um ato negativo não
tenham suporte história que nem uma
estrutura social que deu no jogador e
faz as situações de racismo mais pesadas
leva muitas vezes a interiorização de si
próprios esteriótipos por aqueles que
são vítimas do racismo e isso deve
chamar o racismo incorporava e em casos
mais bicudos leva a que nós chamamos
corista são formas de aquisição dentro
das comunidades realizadas em busca do
branqueamento mesmo que aqueles que são
mais próximos da ideia de branco possam
pensar que tem alguma vantagem na
realidade funcionam sempre em última
instância contra si mesmo e portanto não
é um privilégio
por fim um debate que hoje fazer na
sociedade portuguesa é a idéia de que o
racismo é ao que é estrutural por um avo
o nosso imaginário coletivo é como se
fosse um grande arquivo reúnia imagens
significados articulação de idéias que
ocorrem nesse período as relações
econômicas em que vivemos hoje a nível
global tem chute que tem as suas raízes
também no período colonial e essa e esse
processo atravessam as nossas
instituições e vou falar da instituição
escola
educação o primeiro uma primeira forma
aquilo que chamamos o efeito pigmaleão
quando o professor tem fracas
expectativas sobre um aluno
esse aluno tentar ajustar as
expectativas desse professor e ajustar o
seu desempenho essas expectativas numa
espiral descendente de pai e chama-se
feito pela união
podemos pensar que isso era uma forma de
racismo interpessoal
só que nesta relação existe uma
instituição que o que é a escola e
portanto não há uma relação de um para
um
um professor no ato de ser professor no
exercício do seu papel tempo desde que
ocorrem dessa instituição do profaa de
classificar e demarcar o percurso
escolar de alguém para o resto da sua
vida
a direção escolar a nível do dólar é
óbvio que a seleção escolar não existe
mas nós tivemos de facto ela existe na
nossa no nosso sistema educativo
o programa especial de realojamento
acabou por concentrar a população negra
ea população cigana indeterminado e por
vitórias espirituais são segregados
existem escolas que servem quase em
exclusivo essa proporção
essas escolas também se transformam em
espaço segregado e muitas delas têm
optado por oferecer quase em exclusivo
os profissionais ouvir
profissionalizante que não preparam os
alunos para os heróis em superior em
2013 e 80% dos alunos de nacionalidade
países africanos de língua oficial
portuguesa chegaram ensino secundário
estavam em curso profissionais 80% é o
dobro do que se passava papo com os
alunos de nacionalidade portuguesa e era
quase totalidade desse volume
pergunto quantos de vocês e quantas de
vocês tiveram ao longo do vosso percurso
uma professora um professor negro
quantas vezes estudaram teorias obras de
autores negros enquanto os negros temos
negras
temos nesta sala apresenta atividade é
um espectro da enorme importância da
mobilização
apesar de sabermos que existem turmas só
de alunos chegam às escolas do 1º ciclo
compostas quase exclusivamente por onde
chegamos
escolas e turmas compostas quase
exclusivamente para alunos negros e 15
no cotidiano da vida escolar formas de
violência racista
não temos nenhuma política que procura
mobilizar toda esta realidade e é muito
difícil combater aquilo que não se vê
aliás não ver é uma forma de legitimar e
deixar que funciona em polimento que
funciona por meio deste processo
educação intercultural é uma das vias
pelas quais o nosso sistema educativo
tem criávamos faz para dar conta dessas
questões
mas eu tenho muitas dúvidas que a
educação intercultural
tal qual a ocorre hoje em dia possa
tocar na ferida
raramente ela fala da tal história konya
raramente ela fala sobre as relações de
poder na maior parte das vezes tem uma
concessão na ii sobre o que é o racismo
como se fosse uma questão de segurança
apenas se olharem os nossos manuais
escolares de história
eu sou marcado por uma perspectiva
fundamental cêntrica não sabem nada não
sabemos nada sobre a áfrica sobre os
impérios africanos site o império do
vale do sol guy do gana
a rainha zenga o reino do kongo umas a
moça tudo forma de sensibilização do
fundamento complexa antes da chegada dos
europeus procuraram nos nossos manuais
de história população negra aparece
representada mais ou menos três formas
como escravo como refugiados a tentar
chegar à europa com pessoas em crise
humanitária e política áfrica aparece na
maior parte das vezes sem mapas em
gráficos e tabelas como sítio de onde
saem coisas
donde sai madeira
sai ouro e na mesma listagem como se
fosse equivalente à de escravo
mas o racismo combate e combates com o
conhecimento do problema ponto 1 e
combate também com representatividade é
impossível combater o racismo center tem
um software desenvolvido na frente essa
nessa luta o combate também como a
concessão de igualdade mais abrangente
de paz pela responsabilidade histórica
de paz pela reparação e que passa pela
distribuição mais equitativa daquilo que
são os pais da corrupção é os
privilégios da nossa sociedade e combate
também pela existência de todos nós
obrigada
[Aplausos]